All right, let's get into audience questions,
first question, David.
Why have the opposite?
Why has opposition to covid guidelines been
primarily a right wing thing in the United
States?
The in the United States is interesting.
I don't know if opposition in other countries
has been from the political right or not.
There has been some covid guideline opposition
from the left.
There are some I think there's a subset it
called like Liberal Lockdown's Skeptic's or
something along those lines.
But you're absolutely right that it's been
mostly from the political right.
And I think there's a couple of different
things going on.
First of all, there is this sort of cartoonish
idea of liberty and freedom that exists on
the right, more so than it does on the left.
And it's not that the left doesn't believe
in liberty and freedom, but the left has a
less cartoonish concept of what that means.
So, for example, on the right, things like
liberty and freedom are often assigned to
I can disregard anyone else's public health
concerns and do whatever the hell I want.
That's freedom and liberty on the right.
On the left, we tend to see freedom and liberty
more as we have the freedom and liberty to
live our lives, working wherever we find it,
to be most rewarding without having to consider
whether we will have health insurance at this
job versus that job.
That's the kind of freedom and liberty we
talk about on the left.
So obviously that right wing concept of freedom
and liberty is going to lead people down the
path of needing to wear masks, businesses,
restaurants, having to be take out only.
No, no, no.
That's violating my my freedom and liberty.
The other thing was certainly Trump related.
And what I mean by that is Trump did nothing
early and Trump didn't wear masks.
And Trump was skeptical of what was being
done in different in different parts of the
country with regard to certain governors and
so on and so forth.
So by definition, what Trump wanted was seeing
as seen as the thing for freedom and what
anybody else wanted was seen seen as a restriction
on so-called freedoms.
If you were suggesting something other than
what Trump was suggesting or doing importantly,
then you were the enemy and it was bad and
you were restricting people's freedoms.
Since coronavirus began during the Trump presidency
in an election year, there was this understanding
that anybody suggesting something be done
differently than what Trump wanted was essentially
an indictment of Trump's response, which of
course required much indictment.
It was one of the worst five responses in
the world, according to it, to a recent study.
And what continues to get me about that, even
now with Donald Trump gone, is that as much
as the virus handling was Trump's undoing,
it could have guaranteed his reelection.
It was a wasted opportunity.
Trump and the Republican Party, all they had
to do was stand aside and say, what are the
experts say?
Oh, they say masks.
We're printing American flag masks.
We want to get them out to everybody.
Instead of rejecting the idea of having the
Postal Service distribute masks to everybody,
they don't have to guess the postal service
will be bringing everybody five American flag
masks is the patriotic thing to do.
They could have passed, you know, they could
pass what they passed and more to serve as
a bridge to dealing with the virus.
And Trump would have sailed to reelection
and Republicans likely would still control
the Senate.
So the the idea that it had to go the way
it went down, political lines with the anti
maskers and the anti closures and guidelines,
people saying they are violating our freedom,
they are treading on us and so on because
of the tone that was set by Trump that was
all optional.
However, for Trump to have handled it differently
would have required Trump to be a different
person.
The exact same narcissistic tendencies that
are what a lot of people were drawn to Trump
by were what prevented Donald Trump from doing
what I suggested from the beginning, which
is saying, let's do what the doctors say,
let's be patriots.
It'll be tough, but we're all going to do
it together.
If Trump had had sort of bought into that,
he wouldn't have been Trump in a sense.
And that's part of why he was unable to do
it.
I do think Trump's base would have followed
him.
I got a few emails saying, you know, if Trump
had done this stuff, you're suggesting his
base wouldn't have followed him.
I think that Trump's base was more than willing
to be led in absolutely any direction at any
point in time.
And it was, listen, Trump would have had a
second term had he dealt with it properly.